hassan lança não gosta muito de ler ler
não é uma das atividades preferidas dela
não gosta de brincar de bola e jogando
mas ela começa a conviver com uma
criança que é dois anos mais nova de
tela e ler todo dia todo dia se a
criança mais nova pega uma revista em
quadrinho e se diverte lendo as
histórias compartilhando as histórias
algumas semanas depois de convivência
essa criança mais velha com essa lei
começa a enxergar a leitura de um jeito
completamente diferente
um grupo de três adolescentes na cozinha
fazendo um bolo na hora que eles vão
começar a fazer a cobertura de chocolate
por bono na criança dez anos mais nova
do que eles se aproxima do fogão e pede
pra participar para que ajudar
está na hora de fazer a cobertura vai
mexer com panela com fogo e tal mas
deixam a criança participe e ela ajuda a
misturar o creme de leite ali pra fazer
uma cobertura não gosta muito de jogar
minecraft jhf todo dia por várias horas
constrói coisas joga online quando
começou a jogar na grécia ele conhecia
as letras de imprensa maiúsculas
levantava algumas estava começando a ler
alguns meses depois jogando minecraft
ele chama os adultos que estão perto
para mostrar três livros que ele
escreveu dentro do jogo
três histórias diferentes com começo
meio e fim e para escrever essas
histórias e usou as letras de imprensa
maiúsculas e as minúsculas que aprendeu
jogando duas meninas brincando de faz de
conta brincando com a corda no entanto
várias brincadeiras e um dia a irmã mais
nova de uma delas se junta a brincar com
nós mais nova chega às duas irmãs passam
a excluir a outra menina a outra menina
não consegue participar das brincadeiras
mais
mas não deixa ela participar das
brincadeiras ninguém gosta de ser
rejeitado cps uma menina fica muito
triste
chega perto dos adultos que está
circulando pelo espaço reclama chora
adulto explica que não pode interferir
com a brincadeira não é dele
ela fica triste por um tempo mas depois
elas resolvem rolando um filme na sala
de televisão e filme combina com pipoca
só que não pode comer nada na sala de
televisão uma regra deste espaço
uma criança então pede que um adulto
acrescentar um ponto de pauta na
assembléia que vai acontecer alguns dias
depois que essa regra seja revista
eles querem ver um filme com muito pó os
dias passam chega o dia da assembléia o
ponto de pauta discutida a regra muda ea
partir de então pode-se ver filme e como
pipoca na sala
nossas reuniões que são feitas pra
resolver conversar situações em que
regras de convivência são respeitadas
uma criança pequena é menor a criança
está naquele espaço no momento ela nunca
fica à vontade ela fica magoada fica
tímida ou está a falar
ela não gosta muito dessas reuniões ela
participa de uma duas três
várias um dia o presidente dessa reunião
disse que a secretária não foi pergunta
para as crianças que estão presentes
quem poderia então secretaria a reunião
a primeira pessoa que levanta a mão é
essa criança menor que antes ficava moda
mas agora participam muito essas
histórias têm em comum todas essas
histórias aconteceram aqui em uberlândia
no espaço chamado caso da árvore que é
uma comunidade democrática de
aprendizagem livre e há dois anos e meio
esse espaço faz o seguinte ele permite
que as crianças sejam as responsáveis
pela própria educação delas
nesse espaço as crianças tem tempo pra
brincar livremente para explorar os
recursos do ambiente pra conviver com
pessoas de diferentes idades e observar
pessoas realizando as atividades
interessam para elas
com isso elas aprendem um monte de
coisas aprendem conhecimentos
habilidades coisas que são úteis para
elas
agora e coisas que vão ser muito úteis
para elas quando elas forem adultas a
casa da árvore funciona de acordo com o
modelo de educação e foi criado no final
dos anos 60 nos estados unidos como
modelos a bíblia educação e muitas
muitos espaços e muitas escolas mundo
afora funcionam mais ou menos da mesma
maneira
são todos os espaços democráticos
o que significa que as crianças são
tratadas como pessoas que podem escolher
o que vão fazer com o tempo delas e e
podem votar e podem decidir o que elas
vão fazer e aquilo que vai orientar a
vida coletiva desses espaços e todos
esses passos são pensados pra acolher a
capacidade natural que todo mundo tem de
aprender a aprender uma necessidade a
gente precisa aprender para lidar com o
outro pra resolver problemas e aprender
uma coisa muito prazerosa também esses
espaços eles são eles funcionam como
espaços em que as pessoas podem
exercitar sua capacidade natural de
aprendizagem com que isso como esses
espaços funcionam na prática a equipe
faz com que os adultos fazem a primeira
história que contei para vocês
a história de um menino de 10 anos não
gostava muito de ler não tinha a leitura
uma experiência muito agradável
convivendo com uma criança de oito anos
queria todo dia esse menino de 10 anos
o brasil que lê pode ser divertido ele é
uma coisa legal é uma coisa parecida com
o que aconteceu na segunda história de
um grupo de adolescente estava fazendo
um bolo na cozinha e uma menina de 5
anos chega querendo participar
em comum todos os espaços funcionam de
acordo com o modelo dani em esse
elemento a mistura de idade a gente não
separa as pessoas por faixa etária
então crianças de quatro adolescentes de
18 anos e os adultos da equipe todo
mundo convive junto com isso os mais
novos podem aprender diversas coisas com
os mais velhos são pessoas que ainda não
são adultas mas estamos fazendo o que é
interessante para elas e os mais velhos
podem não só descobrir coisas novas como
foi o caso da leitura
na primeira história mas também
exercitar e desenvolver a paciência o
cuidado ea responsabilidade de ser
modelo de comportamento pra outras
pessoas
a mistura de idades não funciona
situações de aprendizagem mútua muito
interessantes na história do maior craft
aconteceu aprendizagem de um jeito um
pouco diferente
não necessariamente com íntegra
interação entre pessoas é uma criança
que estava jogando minecraft e pra jogar
n craft quem joga sabe você precisa
conhecer as letras precisa saber
escrever e por que você dá certos
comandos para o jogo e mudou o
funcionamento do jogo e quando seja bom
aí você precisa comunicar com as pessoas
então por necessidade para poder jogar
melhor
essa criança de oito anos aprendeu a
escrever e aprender a digitar é uma dica
bem rápido e alê com uma brincadeira
então o efeito colateral ela não estava
jogando o minecraft para aprender a ler
e escrever mas como foi algo que surgiu
da necessidade na brincadeira ela
aprendeu sozinha automotivado sem
necessariamente ter um ambiente
estruturado ou vem ensinando pra ela
além disso essa história conta uma outra
coisa interessante que acontece na casa
da árvore que é quando as crianças e os
jovens realizam alguma coisa conquistar
alguma coisa que compartilham com a
equipe fizeram então esse dia foi muito
legal quando eles chamam a gente pode
escrever três livros uma entrega ninguém
esperava isso foi uma surpresa bem legal
eles costumam compartilhar porque a
gente como é que a gente não ficar
analisando nem julgando nem avaliando
que eles fazem eles se sentem bem à
vontade para mostrar que não estão
fazendo para nós ea gente fica empolgado
com as coisas que eles fazem na casa da
árvore a gente só vai avaliar o que
estão fazendo
as crianças estão fazendo se elas
pedirem caso contrário a gente não vai
avaliar na história do conflito entre as
meninas
essa história é bastante é bastante
difícil pra mim inclusive porque eu sou
membro da equipe da casa da árvore o seu
pai da criança foi excluída das
brincadeiras
então é ela andou mais do que nela né
mas doeu bastante mas também vê a filha
se descuida de uma brincadeira e não
poder interferir porque foge da minha
alçada
só nessas situações de brincadeiras
coletivas de negociação de regras etc
entre eles aprendem várias coisas e se
socializam eles aprendem negociação
empatia é prestar atenção no sentimento
do outro prestar atenção nos próprios
sentimentos né
gerenciar a raiva etc e teve 16 bem bem
interessante essa história da nossa
imagem é uma imagem de uma assembléia
das assembléias acontecem toda semana as
crianças não são obrigados a participar
nas assembleias acontecem porque a casa
da água é uma comunidade democrática
então todo mundo tem direito a voz e
voto tanto as crianças quanto equipe voz
e voto igual pra todo mundo
a assembleia vai decidir tudo que diz
respeito à vida pública as regras de
convivência o uso dos espaços uso dos
recursos então tudo que diz respeito à
vida da coletividade na casa da árvore
passa pela assembléia semanal
assim como as regras de convivência
ele foi mudada na história da pipoca na
sala era proibido como é na sala
isso foi discutido de novo na assembléia
a regra foi revista
apesar da participação não ser
obrigatório
as crianças participam sempre que sentem
necessidade de estar na assembléia
aquilo faz sentido para elas os
adolescentes costumam participar sempre
isso revela também outro aspecto da casa
da árvore é um das crianças vêem os
adultos fazendo coisas que são pra valer
que são de verdade contribuem para o
funcionamento do espaço do grupo elas
sentem vontade de fazer parte sentem
vontade de participar de ajudar a
pergunta é talvez seja a pergunta que
mais escuto lá quase todo dia que você
está fazendo
a primeira então pode ser no caso de uma
reunião como a da comissão de justiça e
foi a história da menina que levantou a
mão para presidir as crianças pedem com
frequência para presidir a reunião da
comissão de justiça a comissão de
justiça a comissão que resolve os casos
de quebra de regras
alguém diz respeito a uma regra essa
comissão que isso é resolvido
as crianças não são obrigadas a presidir
as reuniões inclusive a gente tem um
presidente que está lá o ano inteiro é
guiando o funcionamento da comissão
essas crianças pedem com frequência pra
dirigir se à reunião assim trans percebe
a importância para o funcionamento do
espaço
além das reuniões da comissão de justiça
outras coisas que a gente faz também a
equipe responsável por fazer a equipe
que cuida do espaço
logo em seguida pergunta o que você está
fazendo vem a pergunta também sempre
posso ajudar e aí às vezes faltava a
senhora para a equipe porque todas as
outras estão com as crianças então às
vezes nem tarefa de faxina a gente
consegue fazer sem esperanças que irão
participar seja jardinagem também está
fazendo uma coisa diferente estava
cuidando espaço ela se aproxima e 20
permite que ela se aproxime e permite
que elas ajudem no ritmo delas é a
vontade de contribuir ou instalando um
poste e depois esse vídeo base pra
slackline
a gente trabalha com a premissa de que
todo mundo é capaz de aprender
explorando brincando tudo que é
importante a gente é capaz de aprender
por conta própria interagindo com outras
pessoas buscando pessoas buscando outros
recursos
na verdade todos nós aprendemos desse
jeito na primeira infância
foi desse jeito que a gente aprendeu a
falar foi desse jeito que a gente
aprendeu a andar
foi desse jeito que a gente aprendeu a
comunicação não verbal um olhar um
sorriso aprendeu a controlar o próprio
corpo a segurar o xixi por exemplo a
gente aprende observando os outros
prestando atenção na gente mesmo entre
pessoas que conseguem fazer fazendo
aquilo que a gente tem desejo e
motivados internamente e esse jeito de
educar as crianças
desse jeito não foi inventado pela
sedurb o scope pela primeira escola sabe
do ano e nem pela casa da água é um
jeito de educar ancestral e funcionou
para nós como seres humanos
o dezenas de milhares de anos até
invenção da agricultura é a principal
maneira como as crianças eram educadas
o que a gente faz não é novidade mas não
é por isso que deixa de ser inovador
especialmente se a gente colocar em
perspectiva com a maneira como está
acostumado a ser educado nos últimos 200
anos
a uma educação que passa pela auto
motivação pelo autoconhecimento pela
liberdade pelo direito de participação é
muito diferente do que a gente está
acostumado
nesse sentido algo tão ancestral acaba
sendo muito diferente muito é inovador
a maneira como a casa da água funciona
há mais sintonizada com a há na
sociedade pós industrial que é o que a
gente está começando a visualizar uma
sociedade de automação de criatividade
de inteligência artificial de pensamento
divergente de criatividade de
[Música]
individualidade do que o modelo
industrial
a gente está acostumado uma parte de nós
e educado dentro dele ao invés do modelo
centralizado e padronizado
o que a gente pratica é um modelo de
educação fundado na autonomia e na
diversidade
ao invés de uma em 2000 e ducação
impessoal burocrática educação e
regionalizada e orgânica
nesse sentido a gente acredita que isso
representa um dos futuros possíveis da
educação é o futuro como uma ruptura uma
superação melhoria de algo que já está
acontecendo no futuro e também o apesar
da gente querer fazer previsões ele é
imprevisível
isso a gente se conhece a gente conhece
as nossas próprias capacidades
a gente sabe lidar com o outro a gente
lida com essa imprevisibilidade de uma
forma mais tranquila
a gente acredita que é importante para
as crianças praticarem agora o que é
útil agora o que vai ser muito útil
quando elas forem adultas
então se ser um adulto responsável é
algo importante porque não permite que
as crianças sejam responsáveis pela
própria educação delas transações delas
enquanto antes se saber fazer escolhas
acertadas é algo importante porque não
permite que as crianças façam escolhas
cometam erros aprenda com os erros o
mais cedo possível
se a vida em comunidade
a democracia é tão importante por que
não permitir que as crianças participem
e vivencie a democracia desde seu se a
riqueza cultural na diversidade humana
então vamos respeitar isso na sua
expressão mais singular que é a
individualidade
a gente não está acostumado com isso é
um desafio muito grande para a equipe da
casa da árvore para a equipe das escolas
e do mundo afora
é muito difícil sair desse papel de
adulto que a autoridade que sabe tudo o
que vai resolver os problemas com as
crianças que vai orientar que vai guiar
que vai dizer o que é certo e errado
para resolver os problemas pra ela e vai
sempre ensinar o tc o adulto não ensina
a criança na frente é muito difícil é
muito difícil pra nós olhar para a
criança e de quem ela é agora e não
lidar com a criança que a gente projeta
devia ser neste momento é bem difícil só
que isso não é mais difícil do que
aquilo que queria
estão fazendo todo dia na casa da todo
dia elas estão descobrindo quem elas são
estão descobrindo qual é o lugar delas o
mundo em que elas vivem
isso é bem difícil e antes de terminar
aquela história das três crianças
estavam brincando e as duas irmãs
excluir uma terceira elas as três
crianças resolveram sozinhas aquela
situação ea maneira como elas resolverão
as desavenças foi se tornando as
melhores amigas para sempre
[Aplausos]